so you started your company this year my
great question so I this actually ties
into my past actually so I was at Google
for years I started as their first
filmmaker with the Creative Lab I moved
on five years later into the Google VR
on the Google VR team which is now the
Google a our VR team I don't know they
might be different now I don't know but
they so I became the principal filmmaker
for VR at Google which again is they
talk about titles yeah the fanciest of
titles it was very cool so I helped
develop so jump which was their VR
live-action and kind of capture
ecosystem for live action foot VR
footage and I was making stuff and
working with the engineers and the heart
you know the more that I was working
there I think I found it was very very
tough to be reactive in the beginning it
was super easy cuz it wasn't like VR was
still pretty new and no one really knew
what we should be doing with it yet and
then once it started to solidify it was
much harder to turn the big ship towards
the things that I thought were important
namely you know I thought that there was
something really interesting parallels
between the machine learning team and
the Google brain team and also what was
happening on the VR team and just in
terms of the mediums how similar they
were both in how they've become worked
more present in our lives how they both
kind of were like every was really
excited it all no it doesn't work and
then it was like wait we found this
weird thing that actually makes it work
great so like for VR it was like cell
phone technology actually we have it in
our pocket we can make this stuff work
and with machine learning it was like
right logic is wrong like there's
actually preventing us from doing the
right thing and then teaching these you
know systems how to learn and so
suddenly they both are on this
trajectory and from a creative
standpoint you could see some really
interesting stuff coming from both teams
and I felt that there was a lot of ways
that we could work together on stuff I
also felt that there were lots of
interesting pockets of artistic pockets
where we could create content it wasn't
gonna be like you know with the big
studios it wasn't gonna be like the big
IPS it was really going to be
in these places that needed it
probably more than Hollywood and you
know like thinking about ways that it
could be functional and helpful for
people yeah but also be artistically you
didn't have to be boring and it's not
just functional yeah precisely like
function is actually good because like
films actually serve a function serves a
purpose you know and yeah VR could also
do it any sort of immersive content can
so I thought it was all and I had before
also like worked with I had worked on
some stuff kind of envisioning what the
future would be like when glass was
around yeah and it clearly worked
because everyone now is glass no we're
great but the so for me it was like I'm
really interested in this other layer of
immersive stuff but I also believe that
it's not one technology or another
technology I believe it's all kind of
going towards something they're all
networked together and so a combination
of that belief and wanting to be more
reactive and honestly just working on
the stuff that I felt was important to
me to work on I you know once once that
all sort of became more clear
I felt that once I had left Google that
the best course of action for me was to
actually create my own company and so
for a pictures is the company we crave
for short and has all the letters in it
yeah meaning weight crai crai but so I
didn't want all the letters in my name
because I always thought that was a
little weird for me I mean I it exists
in the in the ecosystem and some people
wear it really nicely for me and my
company I was like I don't know and then
I was in Paris with my with my partner
and he had said I had asked him you know
what's the word for true and he had no
and I was looking for a name so he
immediately was like hold on and he took
a pen he wrote it down he goes that's
what it is and the word for true in
French is vrai so VR AI means true it
actually means real depending on what
how you use it so at that point you're
like okay well I can't not and so you
know this makes absolute sense and so I
started the company in January and it
really really does in a very odd ear
but wonderful way reflects the stuff
that I care about which is how all these
letters all these you know you can pick
it apart even and think you know it's
it's visual arts it's mixed reality it's
all this all these various things that
we we talk about we'll all come together
work together in really wonderful ways
and actually lead to whatever this new
immersive environment will be and I
think you know right now we're seeing
each as like these separate paths and
and I think it's really not gonna matter
I think you see the same the same thing
happens in science it's happening right
now we're like you know physicists and
mathematicians and CS people are all
learning Python yeah and like it's
converging yeah one thing right just
their computers right so like it may be
your deep deep deep dream project is
like the most clear example I think it
is yeah I mean that was really funny
because that's sir so in Seattle so the
jump team I think is still in Seattle I
don't know but they so that the
engineers that are working on the
computer vision people that are working
on the Google like live-action VR rigs
are planted in Seattle at the same
office and it used to be on the same
floor as as the Google machine learning
team that was literally adjacent like
next to each other never really not
intentionally and uh kind of well
they're both computer vision teams okay
so I think that was the whole that was
the reasoning behind I don't know but I
would visit the Seattle team and then I
was fortunate enough to make friends
with the with this particular machine
learning team ai team I was run by this
guy Blaise aquaria our qez he was
amazing so him and some friends of mine
who were working on this team we're
literally sitting two feet away from us
and I had gotten an email from clay
actually on the Google VRI team saying
ARVN team or whatever had emailed me and
and put me in touch with with them
saying you know they're actually an
they're announcing deep dream they
really need a video person to help them
out and so you know they're asking me
what I had I originally just show them
stills of the stuff that I actually
filmed in VR and we started having this
conversation around well I was trying to
push on them the idea that well what if
you're able to dream up on top of mic
the stills of these VR yeah clips then
surely you could do it in such a way
that we can actually experience it in VR
yeah and it was a bit of a
back-and-forth thing I'm like well the
fidelity might not be that great I'll be
low res I don't know if it's gonna be
interesting and then finally they they
dug Fritz who was working on the team at
the time and he he actually gave it a
shot worked his magic and we were like
oh this is actually kind of compelling
yeah um we don't know what it is I think
we're just like dreaming up one stuff
and it was really it was really fun
because I think there was no expectation
it didn't fit on a road map it was
literally just us working together to
see what we can come up with and we
actually worked with Russ Goodwin on do
having his system which was trained on
Faulkner and Vonnegut separately to
actually write prose about what it's all
so and then it would recite it on using
this voice Myra which is an Irish
speaking Irish dialect speaking Apple
voice Apple you know a backup Mac OS
voice which made it really just
unbearable because it was like and we
both sort of like this is kind of
interesting but it's like it sort of
calls to up to mine like less is more in
a VR space you know that's like once
everything's like kind of acid trip II
like hearing this like Irish American
speaking fabricated ladies speaking
Vonnegut interpretations to you just
doesn't isn't ideal right okay how on
earth so we we sort of used it with
caution
yeah yeah I mean it makes sense when you
like change out every variable it just
completely throws you for a loop yeah
it's all kind of closed but sort of
nonsensical it is I mean I think what's
great about what Ross does is that it
actually does it is very poetic but it
gets dark very quickly because well it
Vonnegut Vonnegut a little bit more
upbeat but Faulkner is
you know like yeah so I consider her as
she cuz I hear Mayra all the time every
day yes but it's she sort of says these
phrases that are like sometimes kind of
like normal normalized about like the
world like you know a man with a hat on
a hilltop you know why is he there what
is you know she'll go off on that and
then show that she'll be like the
darkness it it was for me or something
you're all just like this is weird
again it's like us and Turk I mean
what's interesting is that there's it's
all pretty surface stuff and the depth
is stuff that we bring to it which I
really thought I think that part to me
is very fascinating like how we
interpret it is really where the story
where the emotional like foundation
comes from so this is actually like a
big topic I wanted to jump into which is
like framing right so in cinema
obviously it's a director
cinematographer working together yeah to
create the picture that transmits a
story to you sure but in VR like
obviously you have a certain amount of
control but how do you think about that
act like the framing in the storytelling
oh so I don't think it's storytelling
and I think that's the main problem is
that people think you know I think story
is extremely important to the medium I
think storytelling is kind of like it's
sort of like you want to get to
something that's important so you take a
pill to make you feel that way like say
like a sleeping I need to go to sleep I
need something to help me sleep somebody
take a sleeping pill I don't recommend
that saying that's something you should
do is just something that some people do
I think storytelling is the act of
taking that pill so it's like yeah you
may take that pill you might you know
take you might exercise before you go to
bed it's it's a means to an end but it
itself is not the end and so for film
storytelling was the way that you got to
story and a lot of mediums the telling
part was actually really important
because you couldn't actually take those
people and put them where you were
thinking and now you're in a medium
where you can so telling doesn't really
work anymore you don't need that it's
like if you think of it as you know you
know kinetic versus potential story
right
so kinetic is storytelling it's the idea
that actively I am trying to take you
and put you over there so it's this kind
of active thing that's that's occurring
for VR the way that I've been looking at
it is it's more potential story it's I'm
crafting worlds that you where if when
you go there the story is something that
you can decode right so it's like how do
these worlds transmit the story or
represent the story right so that no
matter how you interact with that world
you're able to sort of decipher or get
to the core to the core values of what
that story's trying to transmit okay
it's a bit in the same line as in like
an Aesop fable in a way it's like slow
and steady wins the race if that's what
you're going for it's not about the
turtle or the bunny it could be anything
yeah it's about that's the core value of
the story that's what we want the
takeaway to be and so in my mind in VR
or any immersive content if you can get
that piece that truth transmitted to
that person yeah doesn't matter what
kind of experience they have they walk
away with what was most important you're
in the first place I mean how do you
think about that in the context of you
know video games do you think that is
just a transition to immersive content
do you think it's it's fair for certain
games already I think certain games
provide what's interesting about games
for me is is this idea of flow which is
it's very musical in nature the best
games are where they give you the
capacity to explore at your leisure
you know some of my favorite games have
been like something like mists you know
I actually loved Red Dead Redemption a
lot because you know yeah okay it's
really stressful this this like this
like rail that we're putting you on
maybe you just want to take a break and
train some horses over there and that's
fine and then you can duck back into the
story when you want to this idea that
you can be in a completely explorable
place you can do all sorts of things
that you want but then there is this
rail that you could go on and duck in
and out of I think that to me is very
compelling miss had that same sort of
rail as well it's it is definitely a
different kind of game if it's like okay
you do have a do you have this and
that's all you can do and you can't move
forward until you do that like a Super
Mario Brothers is
example any of the earlier games
literally yes yeah that's cool sure and
I mean I think that's something that we
need to be aware of as as creators in
the space too when we talk about games
we don't mean if there's no it's not a
catch-all yeah
like different games serve different
purposes pawns different in Super Mario
Brothers which is different than Mis
which is different in some ways or a lot
of ways from Red Dead Redemption to like
Red Dead Redemption at least gives you
new elements that are you're used to
dealing with like it works sort of
similarly the way the world works
like okay that's a gun that's an evil
person that's like it's easy to kind of
decipher it and miss the whole point was
that you had no idea what you were doing
pulling levers the first thing you do is
there's a book on the ground and then
you go and then there's a lever and you
don't know what the lever frickin does
you know and nothing happens and you're
like is this gonna be the rest of the
game yeah and it is and many of those
games like pre-internet we're so hard
now you just go on youtube and it takes
two minutes to figure out what you're
doing yeah I know I know actually when
am i there was an old game from the 90s
called amber journeys beyond which is
actually has been a inspiration on a
recent project and it's really great
because there's some well it was just a
really great game it was sort of a
missed ish copy made by two guys I don't
think they made anything after that but
they ended up we well you can't play it
anymore or at least have an emulator and
a piece of hardware that will help you
run it but they I have a there's a
there's a bunch of playthroughs on
YouTube
and I actually sat there with a glass of
wine in order they watch my like I
remember it was such a beautiful
experience actually where I'm like okay
I actually love watching other people
play these games and the commentary is
really beautiful too
I think one of my recent my own and my
recent favorite games is from Davy Reid
and the beginner's guide it's wonderful
because it literally sets it up and says
this is a 45-minute game because most of
these games really I don't know who's
gonna take off my life but it's it's
basically you're on Rails but it's him
and he kind of gives you he voiceovers
and it's about this other game creator
who's
created kind of these weird
psychological like very basic games so
like it's weird it's like he built this
character that you never see and the
game this character is someone you
explore through the games pieces of
games as his character is me yeah and
Davies is taking you through it as if he
knows this person but then you start to
question whether or not this narrator
actually knows this person or not or if
this person gave Devi the permission to
showcase his games like this so suddenly
you start to question everything as
you're going through this like kind of
game it's it's I think it's really
brilliant I think any game that kind of
takes it takes the format and then
through your interactive through your in
through the interactivity through your
agency kind of makes you feel these
different things
uh-huh I think that's a huge win for
games especially and I think that is
where immersive needs to go Florence
which I think just won the Apple Design
Award for like best designed game this
guy Ken Wong who was the designer on
Monument Valley as well started his own
company in Melbourne he's an amazing
creator and he this game Florence is all
about using you use your phone the way
that you would normally use your phone
but the story you feel for the story
based upon the way that you would feel
for like conversations and interactions
with your phone so moments of
frustration is like you know not hearing
back from the person for like three
minutes yeah like that kind of thing
they can see all those things yeah
absolutely like how fast you like how
you reveal things you're like the whole
idea of swiping it's just very smart
yeah and I think that's the thing it's
not we try to shove a lot of this stuff
through preconceived notions and
conventions we're embracing how
technology works now and using those
limitations as a means of telling a
story in some capacity or understanding
a story in some capacity I think that's
me is really fascinating have you played
have you played the game this is really
embarrassing because I met the creator I
think it's called like black box or
something the iPhone game where's all
the puzzles so for instance like one of
the puzzles you have to put your phone
in
and the temperature has to hit certain
and then you unlock it
that's brilliant yeah that's good stuff
like that where I'm like that's just so
because it makes you question your like
relationship with a device totally you
know and I think that's an interesting
thing because that the the that story
yeah is potentially as good as some of
the films that you've seen of course you
know and it again it's like it's not 1:1
but it still gets you to the same place
mentally and emotionally yeah so so okay
so when you left Google did you have a
project in mind or were you just going
to client stuff I wasn't sure what I was
gonna do I just knew that I needed to go
I think that the the what I ended up
doing first was I took I kind of got a
lay of the land sort of explored what
other people were doing talked to some
folks thought about the things that I
wanted to do I think for me I needed a
little bit of time to sort of get a
sense of what was out there it's it's
difficult because when you work for a
company for that long you're like oh
okay like my problem was water water
everywhere but not a drop to drink kind
of where it's like oh I have all this
stuff yeah yeah but I can't do anything
with it and then one of my limitations
was like beyond that was um you know I
had I had seen where interactivity was
going a lot of ideas for that I could
see where augmented reality in VR could
could talk to each other where machine
learning techniques in VR could talk to
each other I couldn't do any of that
other than the stuff that I could kind
of sneak through I think in frustration
I made what I believe to be sort of like
a VR gift type thing which was The
Weather Channel project that I did that
was my favorite one I know I don't need
to be down on you know there are other
really ambitious ones but that was my
favorite yeah well it's most people's
favorites because they get it it's like
immediately apparent it's and it's also
like it's hilarious yeah yeah and it's
one of the things that people are always
asking was well how do we make comedy in
VR and they try to bring comedians on it
I'm like it's not doesn't have to be a
literal thing you know you don't it does
not to be like slapstick eora like
here's you know frickin like Jerry
Seinfeld telling you a joke like it's
it's literally just like what what is
the human condition like what have we
created for ourselves in light of spaces
and experiences that are just inherently
funny yeah oh and the Weather Channel
just happens to be like watching The
Weather Channel it's one of those things
Oh totally it was very Adult Swim that's
like the little infomercials yeah it was
really great and I think that to me and
I made that in a day
yeah that's not surprising no but I mean
it but considering how long usually it
takes to make VR it's insane and I can
show it tell you one of my phone I don't
care if they watch it on YouTube and low
res or high res like it's one of those
things that you could just show anyone
and I I love that stuff and I still
think that that stuff's very important
as well
so there's all that stuff and just this
idea that I felt that I yeah again being
reactive seeing how everything works
together creating a wide variety of
stuff I think I did wanna but I also
really wanted to to create like I had to
work in a 3d environment or like a
three-strike 360 stereo environment
which for me was actually really great
because it forced me to understand how
something like just looking around was
still very interactive it wasn't and I
cuz I think that that and how we
actually experience a space and how
those spaces engage with us that is the
that is an important part of this medium
I don't know if I wouldn't necessarily
come to that conclusion if I had made
mmediately like volumetric and sixth off
and you can you know you can speak whale
so for me I think that was it was
important to have those limitations so
that I could see within her I could
explore within the medium just some of
the basic building blocks of what made
it so special but that that said I
really wanted to make volumetric sick
stuff whale calling VR experiences I
just wanted to do more and I want to
work with different technologies and
different VR companies and really expand
what I was doing and I felt as someone
who was in the space early enough and
who had the fortune of sort of being
around the medium and it's sort of
second resurgence I felt that I had the
opportunity
at that moment to actually do some good
yeah so so what's coming out next so I
can't yeah I was thinking about what I
could talk about yeah and I can't I feel
like I I've been told I need to be
patient I'm probably not talking about
anything yet but I think I can say that
one of the things that has been really
amazing is um the response to me going
solo ish was really it was pretty good I
mean it was like I got so many people
coming up wanting to work with me and
you know pretty like big names and IPS
and so on so the the projects that I
have I can say that there are four
projects one is with a pretty big IP
which is a series which we're in
development with right now still working
out how that will work but we were
excited about it then and I feel like
that's really interesting because that's
both it's it's something that explores
the biopic and how we reimagine that
sort of experience in VR in a way that
that feels like a journey it feels like
you're going somewhere special yeah so
that that's sort of the crux of the
series the awesome because bio pics are
so bad usually the music ones are so
disappointing every time well the first
one out of the gate will be a music one
great so that should be that should be
fun oh you blow the doors off of it yeah
yeah thank you no I think it's difficult
because I think music has a I mean has a
capacity to transcend and be emotionally
valuable as well and so I think that for
for me was an important part plus this
particular person is a very epic
cultural icon so it's it's it's a
wonderful it's been a very interesting
experience getting to know who this
person is on a deeper level many many
levels the second projects with an
architect who's pretty well known and
it's sort of it's a combination of it's
more exploratory kind of figuring out
what we should be doing with his work
third is a game a fringe game probably
more in the weather channel from here
which I'm very excited about because
it's ridiculous and
I think but I feel like if there were
needed to be a game that was more like
what would kind of help do what pong did
for folks where you know I wanted to
have a game that was simple enough that
people could all understand and play and
would be also sort of an introduction to
like what immersive stuff was come on go
pokemons go to me is still a bit complex
for folks like I feel like it's it's I
think it totally helped people get the
hang of things I'm thinking about like
what can be uniquely VR like you know
like not taking an original IP like yep
like a poking sure yeah it's more like
can we create something that is from the
ground up something that was built for
this space okay
based upon like thinking about the way
that defaults are built thinking like
thinking more in that like kind of retro
grade like basic geometry oh yeah not
not like complex character world yeah
but complexity comes with it
longer conversation oh so and I think
the fourth was the fourth one that was
so I'm trying to think it's really hard
to keep them straight that's okay and
the fourth the fourth one is actually um
an immersive audio project I think that
immersive audio is great I think we've
talked about to perform it yeah I feel
that there's you know as the visual
fidelity changes all the time and as
someone who creates in the space it's
annoying because like every time I
headset comes out you have to rehab
sport like it refers specifically for a
live action I think it's probably a bit
easier yeah for probable I'm gonna hear
back from people beginning it's Nadia's
you're in volumetric or sixth off but
the but the audio guys were like we good
you know they just like lean back like
yeah I'll be exported as whatever kind
of like you need to 5.1 here you need
like you know like what kind of a
Masonic what kind of spatial eyes like
file format and it's very I'm not this
is not - they're extremely talent like
the bright the people who are talented
or amazing of course who know how to do
it or incredible yeah
it just feels like that stuff is so
important in terms of selling you being
in a space and it's again people are
trying to think of it second so I want
to be part of the I want to lead helped
lead the charge and like its first for
me yeah I totally agree with you that's
uh people don't realize that you could
shoot this podcast on a Motorola RAZR
from ten years ago yeah video yeah and
then use these mics and that would be
good enough yeah audio is so much more
important than HD anything absolutely
yeah and no one gives it any love no I
mean like I'm thinking about the Weather
Channel piece again it's like Kenny do
you really hit it out of the park
understood yeah yeah all right let's go
into all the Twitter questions so first
question sure Andrew Peterman Andrew
Peterman asks how long until we'll be
able to create 3d 360 video from cell
phone hardware and some kind of software
ballpark guesstimate oh I mean you can
kind of do that now yeah I think it's
pretty good already yeah it's a
storytelling challenge or not whatever
it whatever what's the word une is no
story time I mean I can speak to what is
the what's I mean the question is like a
rather than storytelling what would you
prefer to say oh oh god I don't know
world building that's the one that I can
think of okay it's weird again it's like
the director question we don't really
know what to call it so we just it could
be anything close enough okay cool story
crafting narrative narrative is good you
know creating a narrative I'm trying to
think back to all the all the all the
decks I've made in the past couple
months and I think they're a few were
I've definitely used narrative story
crafting story crafting experience
making experiences I think time will
tell
yeah yeah not the most important thing
another no it's all semantics it's like
you just make stuff that's that's
meaningful and oh no totally it's like
the hardest part is any creative person
you're like dude I know you want to put
me in a box so here's the box but I'm
gonna do
then I actually created this is I love
this because I haven't used this phrase
in a while but I came up with my earlier
eat my earlier days of working I was
trying to explain how I edited World
Tour together and the the thing that I
had called it was probabilistic
experiencial editing which the acronym
is P and I remember what I was putting
this together
for for a presentation
I noticed it and I was like either I can
pretend like that's not the acronym or I
have to call that [ __ ] up and so I
basically called it out was like I know
yeah but in the beginning of every media
you know people are gonna say some weird
[ __ ] and it may not last but here you go
and yeah people actually the response
was very positive because I think
sometimes people are so serious like
well this is what this is called way and
it's like well it doesn't have to be it
could be called anything we can call it
cheeseburgers and it'd be like yeah and
if you have the confidence and you make
cool stuff no one's gonna be like oh
that's not wrong like Jessica's wrong
yeah dude I make the cool stuff another
another V our future question Matt asks
where do you see VR in ten years I don't
see being called VR okay sure
like I just don't see it I think that
it's all gonna go to a different kind of
place I think yeah I think I'll be
called something else mm-hmm related
Michael Hodapp asks does VR or whatever
you want to call it still have long-term
mass adoption potential or will the
market shift to a are you know so magic
leap Apple glasses stuff like no I think
I think that's already happened in a lot
of ways like I think you could see that
just in the shift of Google's like cut
like yeah it's like it was Google it was
cardboard than Google VR then Google VR
hair then Google a are VR
so it's like you know they don't relieve
it's like people are still there trying
to be like okay what's gonna be the most
what's gonna be the easiest thing for
people to croc though there's part of
there's an AR project that I'm working
on or will hopefully be working on that
is um it's similar where it's you know
everyone has phones in their pockets
everyone can download apps so there are
these two things that are like easy
enough for people to grok
where it's like okay I get I get it
don't it's not like I have a new piece
of hardware that I have to learn I think
that I still have a hard time finding
compelling content on a r4 in the AR
sphere as well so I think similarly to
like where VR is gonna be in ten years I
think that a lot of these technologies
which are by themselves have weakness
weaknesses weak spots yeah well when
together kind of fulfill each other's
gaps fill each other's gaps so like you
can imagine okay AR AR is great because
it's the most accessible thing yeah you
build a relationship with a particular
app that leads you into the VR space
because now you actually cuz with VR
it's like you kind of need people to
care enough to want to do it so if you
have an AR experience that is compelling
enough that does speak to you in some
emotional level and the fact that VR a
VR experience can be there to help like
expand upon that like that's a simple
like off the top of my head way that
those two could work together yeah is it
compelling to you the notion that in
pick a number of years people will be in
dr for a significant percentage of their
day I mean people kind of are aren't
they and with computers and cell phones
like we spend so much time on the
internet yeah me if you really want to
do that you could probably go to that
level of like well we do we spend so
much time not here as it is yeah so it's
like I mean we've seen the effects of
that in some way it hasn't destroyed us
but it has sort of it's had
ramifications to the way that we work
live right relationships right so I
think I had a I think I told you that
story about the hedgehogs and the like
the plasma screen oh yeah I went to the
lounge at Heathrow and I saw these
plasma screens with these hedgehogs on
them for some sort of AI system
advertisement and I'm thinking like
Blade Runner called this in a very just
you know kind of semi dystopic way like
look at it's just everywhere and it's
all over the place and I'm like it still
is it just has hedgehogs right so it's
probably not gonna be anything that's
gonna just just its dock pop it's
probably not we destroy humanity like we
do a great job doing that oh yeah we're
on track I think the technology itself
is something that challenges the way
that we exist
and will provide us with with ways to to
have conversation around that I don't
think it itself will be the cause of any
sort of insane thing I I I'm actually
not like I'm not negative about it I
think people are just interested in
altering their perception and like you
mean you see it when people like watch
folks on Twitch I think you see it with
like you know deprivation tanks try
those yes really awesome
they are amazing yeah I mean that to me
that's what's so great about like with
people are like oh when you go into VR
and you do a billion things like no you
don't do anything like sometimes people
just want to hang out like oh for sure
and just like chill for a second that's
the thing I think that's very valuable
for you know for VR right now at least
is the idea that you can focus yeah and
it does have that meditative quality
that's really great
I also think that you know the potential
for having it hospitals having it places
where people are they're sitting anyway
and it's all whole like the idea that
you can have someone in a VR experience
and not feel so bad is is a great it's a
great idea my dad I gave my dad an
oculus go recently he loves it my mom's
been taking photos of him using it he
fell asleep and one which was really
pretty entertaining and that's I mean to
me them like that's how I know it's
gonna be fine cuz I mean it's just it
literally is it's it's just it looks
he's fine like it's just him being like
yeah I was watching this thing and I
fell asleep I don't know what he was
watching it didn't ask
it was my project but I think that
there's something really there's
something really sweet about that where
it's like it's just another thing for us
to experience the world yeah just
falling asleep in front of your TV yeah
I'm reading a book or whatever yeah I
don't like I do think that there's for
example I actually realized I needed
glasses when I was make starting to make
VR because I couldn't rectify the I
couldn't the stereo justice no no stereo
disparity so I couldn't actually took me
a while for me to see my left and right
eye for close-up like Oh wouldn't
wouldn't match so they'd still seem like
they weren't working and I sent it to an
engineer and I said you know that
is my text right because I it doesn't
seem to look right and he looked at
apparently looked at it and said you
know like well that's you know the fonts
kind of weird and I was like what do you
mean the [ __ ] doesn't work he's like oh
yeah no it looks great
he's like are you sure your eyes are
okay and I went to an eye doctor and
that sure enough I had like I had a
stigma thing so now I'm funny yes it's
weird so I mean even that kind of like I
feel like there's some interesting ways
of of how there's a there all sorts of
things that will come to the surface
from once people start to like actually
adopt and experience this stuff right I
do think from a VR stand right now
people are sitting there with their VR
headsets yeah but I you know all the
headsets are going towards volumetric
like you know positions Wireless so I
imagine they're being you know I'm much
much more interactive much more engaging
like you're not just sit there you're
gonna actually move around have you been
to that I think it's in like Utah or Las
Vegas it's like some laser tag type
thing where you have a VR headset on oh
it's the it's oh my god why am i
blanking on it yeah they have a Star
Wars experience - I'm gonna get reamed
for this I don't remember the name of
this company but it's a yeah they
basically do like kind of a
location-based entertainment they do
best Buster's thing also that is okay
they yeah they do I really feel bad
about this I want to say valve but
that's not true at all it's like
although all the game talk I feel like
they actually yeah they do I think that
stuff's really cool I think it fits
within again it's like it's a different
genre of VR for game where I feel like
that's a that's a very what they've what
they've figured out you have that you
have to dedicate like a space for that
kind of thing because what you're doing
is you're letting people move seemingly
move through a whole experience and I do
believe that taking that first step in a
VR space for a lot of people is really
it's powerful it's a powerful thing to
feel I
we were running some very very basic
like if we took three six the three
like World Tour film that I made if we
put it in a space and like kind of
created like evenly if it was like a
rudimentary like box with like what the
floor would look like and gave you space
to move I mean I I did that and I lit
almost like I was very emotional for me
because I remembered what it was like to
be there on a level that seeing it was
couldn't do anymore
like you could see it and be like yeah I
was there and then you move you're like
no but I was really there and that's
where it's like holy [ __ ] like when
we're able to actually capture our own
personal moments like that where we can
relive them that to me is like kind of
terrible I mean I've said it before
where it's like okay you know part of
the human experiences that we forget of
course so when you can't forget anymore
what happens when you can't like where
you're because I don't I believe in the
sanctity of experience in the human
experience that's my own opinion on it I
don't think that we should have all the
world's experience is accessible to
people all the time I think that's a
that's a terrible idea and I don't like
the way that that's been marketed as
such like I think that there are there
are things that are poetic to forget and
should be forgotten in some way and I
worry that it my worry of this is that
it goes in the opposite direction where
everyone's like remember everything
great experience everything worse
access to everything yeah once we index
all of our memories and be perfect as
long as there's Hedgehog's on a plasma
screen saying AI systems and it's an app
like I as long as those exist in that
kind of way I think there's hope yeah
because it's like that actually brings
it to a place where it's like this stuff
is being adopted but in a way that's
like it's essentially harmless it's like
once you start thinking once you start
getting into that like the bare bones of
like why people are trying to do this
like what the end goal is for some of
this stuff that stuff gets a little
weird but like I think right now I we're
in a really nice we're in a reasonably
nice place with some of this well I
think it's like
whenever you are a nun VRA are so it's
bringing people joy at this point so I
don't think it's really seeded fear in
ways that other technologies have I
think you know you it's we were talking
about this like it's it's only AI and
until it's cleaning your floors and then
it's a Roomba yeah there were just like
my friends I know it's like we have so
much like AI intelligence systems around
us now I speak to Google home every day
I would you know speak to Syriac Asian
aliy like it doesn't fine you know it
does it doesn't even doesn't faze me at
all to do that but ask me five years ago
if I would talk to a little speaker in
my kitchen and ask it to set the timer
for me for grilling it would be like I
wouldn't really understand what I was
talking about let's go let's go into the
craft so Virginia pegado asks how can a
traditional storyteller adapt to VR and
actually I don't know this about you
either were you making films before yeah
I was a filmmaker so I my a quick
background on my life was that I I was a
film I studied film at NYU okay and at
the same time I was running across the
street to Crump the crown Institute of
math I mean tell me that's all okay and
so I see you know Courant
so I was there and I got a minor in
computer applications not computer
science because I got to pearl and I
hated it so I was like no way in hell am
I gonna like spend my time thank you so
much languages like turn people off I
can't stand it but I so I would go back
and forth between these two schools I
didn't know about ITP never heard of it
so I'm either and if I had I would have
totally gone there so it was this kind
of sorry I went to both schools did that
I have shorts I worked at Apple for a
little bit I worked at a place called UV
factory as their lead editor for a bit
and then I ended up at Google and Google
was it was always like that back and
forth like science art science art and
then our technology film I guess were
the two I
then Google had a position open for a
filmmaker or film it was like film
editor at first but then turned it a
filmmaker when I got there so I started
working there with the creative lab
which at the time was like ten people
the one in Chelsea yeah exactly and now
has become like a huge is a very it's a
very important part of Google actually
they create magical things about the you
know the brand and like they they they
kind of tell Google's story about their
products and I was part of that you know
how do we use films how to how to be
artful about these films so it's not
talking heads and engineers that look
really nervous so I ended up working
with them for five years before I went
into VR and actually the VR team
the people there working on the camera I
think found that it would be better if
they just tried to look internally to
see if someone could use the rig so they
wouldn't have to rely on external stuff
we'd be more cost effective to try to
find me than you know so and I remember
they had emailed me I actually kept the
email because it was huge turning point
because I was actually feeling kind of
bored to be honest like these film yeah
cuz it was a bit like again it's that
idea that I wanted to do more and I felt
like what I could do more mm-hmm
and then when when the VR I wasn't
really interested in VR at all to be
honest I just wasn't I didn't think it
was for me or I didn't really think
about it at all but then my you know a
bunch of my friends started working in
it like Aaron Koblin and Chris milk
started with verse at the time which is
now within sashka Unseld
went to oculus has started a story
studio so there are all these people
that I had known who were starting to
get more involved with VR but I again I
wasn't thinking about it and then sure
enough I get invited to see this rig and
experience the footage and there was one
clip that it was a test footage of the
clip that the engineers had filmed of
just themselves hanging out in Seattle
and it was brilliant like it was
wonderful because I'm like try making
films about these engineers and it's
really hard you know I feel like I was
mostly successful in doing it but it was
hard to get engineers to be as relaxed
you know egg normal are you talked about
what they what they love about this
stuff because when they do they it
totally makes sense yep
I think there used to like well I have
to talk like this and I'm not so I do
like no idea what you're talking about
yeah but then I I think seeing that I
was like right this is actually this is
the truth
yeah of that so to really quickly answer
the question yeah how did traditional
storytellers adapt to be are right you
abandon the telling yeah
as hard as that is you think about what
I do actually is I draw two x's and in
brackets I write down what I want to
what what the story that I want to tell
okay and I use a whiteboard I love
whiteboards I don't know if it's the
Google thing that I love whiteboards
because it's sleep it's non-precious you
can just like write and then erase it
and it doesn't exist so I I write down
even if it's long-winded and crazy I'll
write down what I believe this story is
and then I'll look at it and start to to
hack away at it till I get to that truth
statement so I'll like it'll be some
like if it's a tourist in the hair it's
like the entirety of that narrative and
then it's like you know slow and steady
wins the race might be the end you know
result you know so I reduce I mean I
kind of feel you're sort of sculpting at
that point you're sort of like here's my
the story the story I would tell is this
big block of clay within that clock of
clay is the actual meaningful bit yes I
mean that's like the Michelangelo quote
right it's like I see it in the marble
and then I like bringing out literally
what you're saying okay well then I
think that's aim aim for that and I and
it's also thinking about you know as a
once you get to that truth and it's
really about holding it's like you're
north story and it's about for me after
that once you get to that you have to
also think about the flow of the
experience thinking about the cadence
how people come into spaces how they
relate to other objects Hillary to other
people thinking about the various
elements that you want to bring into it
so it's layered thing is their inner I
like like thinking about the tech as
well like it's not film in the sense
okay you edited an final cut or premiere
or whatever you export it you put it on
FTP and you send it to somebody right
it's like the process is very much in
flux yeah so a lot of the things you
have to consider or who's my audience
where is this going to go which had set
what kind of limitations are there for
the headset are they creative
limitations are they annoying
limitations and then you really have to
understand like you know how those
limitations play into the the truth that
you're trying to transfer over and again
thinking how is that truth constantly
represented in this experience how do I
make sure that regardless of where
someone is engaged with either what I
believe is front/back wherever like how
is it even at its worse still able to
transfer that over to somebody so yeah
it's a lot of like really the
pre-emptive stuff it's like kind of
figuring out you know what are one of
the things I call is like what is what
is the what is the superpower for the
person in the experience like in a game
oh man okay you know I mean like in a
game you're like okay I can jump I can
like throw a fireball if I have one eye
I can go this way but not that way
so being giving people the time to
understand that first and foremost is
also important but understanding what
those things are and how that evolves
over time is part of the narrative too
and could like I don't know if it's like
the companion cube in Portal where
you're given an object that's meant to
help you and does help you but then it's
incinerated like three layers in because
the computer like wants you to feel to
it yeah yeah and you do and it works and
so it's that kind of like when you're
given this gift to do something
incredible and then you know halfway
through you're it's taken away from you
mm-hmm I don't know what I don't wanna
spoil Red Dead Redemption but like so
sorry at this point okay so there's the
second one coming out soon okay but you
know you're playing this character John
Marcin and you get to the end and you
realize that you can farm like you get
your wife back and your kid back and you
you know you've been trying to help the
FBI is this outlaw for the entire game
you beat your
kind of enemy former colleague and then
they let you go and you get your wife
back and your kid back you can farm and
then the FBI comes back in a rampage and
kills you and you can't win there's no
like and you're just like holy [ __ ] look
what happened and then you die that's it
in that's life and there's nothing you
do about it and then for the last little
bit you play your son okay and then you
and your play the son and then your son
is now taking revenge on his father's
death and he turns out in a way the
whole Red Dead Redemption is about the
son Renate not at redeeming his father
not the father redeeming whatever else
which was always a little bit you know
like I guess like getting back to add
his gang for having abandoned him I
don't know but the real redemptions with
the son and that's when you're like wow
okay that's when you're like because
you're suddenly like terrified you're
like I did everything that I could and
you did yeah and you still failed you
still filled right because life that's
sometimes life and that's how you set up
a second game that's how you set up all
right let's really go rapid fire through
these questions so Ken also asks what
what key but non obvious thing is
missing from VR to become mainstream
people not just focusing on
entertainment and games I think that a
lot of what I've been doing has I mean
granted one of the pieces I'm making is
entertainment but thinking about
education and thinking about various
other me uh you know professions that
could use in infrastructure architecture
like you know the other project I'm
working on
thinking about I don't know where this
stuff could actually be useful don't do
those things artfully and I think that
we kind of just try to focus on doing
this one thing and it forgets like but
you know we could just find be inspired
by other places where like yeah like
I've gotten I've had people come up to
me saying like is VR important to us and
sometimes I'm like I actually hope that
might work through the the stuff with
them and I say actually no is I useful
it might be useful in the future
I think right now it's it would be weird
if you did it yeah I think like this is
a you know as technologies expand in
popularity so quickly no yeah they just
become hammers and people are looking
for nails wait block train yes we
haven't black just white why why do you
say that
no it's for sure it's like this was
driven by a I really I don't think a I
don't think it was yeah you're like why
would you do that
it's like there's no reason yeah it's
like kind of you know I think that
that's it's more figuring out where I
where you can have where that stuff that
technology myself included where we
could have like the most impact and
still be creative and still Explorer and
I think people who really do want this
from other sectors are also really
open-minded at least the people have
work from been working with to explore
those how it could be really interesting
and and wonderful for people yeah yeah
totally all right next question
Matt MacCabe asks what are some of the
most exciting or scariest parts of
social VR and what is the storytelling
potential of social you also what would
a social vr social vr is well it means a
lot of different things that's another
well okay so it's social could mean like
it's a way for your friends or followers
to basically it's about the idea of like
sharing the experience with another
person that's ultimately what it got you
okay so it could be like either you're
represented by a avatars in the space
and there's multiple or it's multiple
people being able to do the same
experience at the same time it could
mean all those things at the same time -
I did alt VR I think that's what it's
alts basis sorry old space VR and for
the first time like I think a month ago
I just was curious I just hadn't been
able to do it for awhile and so I did it
using the oculus go and I I was changing
my avatar like because you're a robot
and then it can be like three or four
other things and meanwhile this couple
comes along and they start talking to me
and I am looking over at them as they're
talking to me and I'm still changing my
avid
and I and I kind of like give him a look
and I look away and I for me because you
know you're thinking okay it's a game
and stock it up but then you realize
they're actual people behind that yeah
and I just probably looked like someone
who just gave him the cold shoulder like
oh it's you and just like look I was
like I don't I don't even know how to
talk I'm still a freakin robot like I
don't know how to do this and I look in
the distance and there's another robot
and that robots looking at a fire and
it's Harding the fire because you can
basically shut up throw like a motor
cons at things so it's like heart heart
heart heart yeah ones throwing a stick
and all I could think of was this is
beautiful
this is a beautiful thing because
everyone's just like I'm just gonna try
out a bunch of stuff course but this is
probably where chat rooms were for like
AOL back in the day where you're like
this is great we're all like one big
happy family learning from each other
but then there's also like then the
creeper comes through and destroys
everything for everyone so I think that
the fear is that people there are
creepers out there they're there you
know there's been a lot of talk about
you know women being mistreated yeah in
that space as well I think the same
patterns of what we've experienced
before in digital space is probably
gonna be the same problems we would
potentially deal with ya know and again
it's like it's more affecting because
it's like it's it's trying to emulate
real life to some extent so these
experiences are a bit more they stick to
kind of this role yeah yeah so we have
to be very careful about that sort of
thing I mean it's one of the reasons why
I think games with guns are I mean it's
hard because I think that VR experiences
should not be following in the same
footsteps of games in that regard
because holding a gun to someone's head
is very different than holding a
controller so that that character can
hold a gun to someone's head it's like
once you actually put a gun in the hands
of a kid in the in a space it's starts
to get like there's heavy responsibility
there and I think that's where we do you
would need to be very careful and very
responsive how we create these things
well let's end on a happy note
Tony Tony kisara asks probably the most
pertinent question what kind of dog do
you have this is from your Twitter bio I
think right you have a dog yeah I have a
German Shepherd mix I adopted him I
would use five months name is Fisher
he's great I actually he hates VR know
when I'm in VR he gets very upset he's
just like where'd you go like he's kind
of like but what about me and I think
for him it's like he's started used to
it but he does this whole like had a
heals like lay down in the middle of the
floor near where I'm doing it and kind
of Huff like him here yeah but yeah he's
he's cool I one of my favorite talking
about memories and so on like that like
I've actually the benefit of having been
able to work with the jump rig so early
on was that I was able to take a lot of
the prototypes and I took one home oh
cool yeah and I filmed my family and my
my house kind of where we're later part
my life where I grew up and we're
actually we're parents moved after
various other stints other places and
there's a shot of me playing with with
my dog and like just us like running
around and you know right now it's like
yeah whatever that's silly that's that's
dumb but I imagine myself you know years
from now you know looking back and being
very happy yeah seeing that happened to
me too that you know I've had you know
one of my producers passed away actually
the person who worked on world tour with
me passed away like a few years ago and
one of the things that I had to grapple
with was like do I give his parents this
VR footage is that okay and his you know
we figured out a way to do that where
there he had a friend of his actually
was working at jaunt and so his john
friend was also there kind of but it's
that question to where it's like it's so
wonderful to have these experiences like
to be able to remember some of the
things that matter to us a lot and I
think you know even though it's you know
what I'm trying to do is is trying to
combine these three different
technologies or more it's also about
what's the conversation all the stuff
will
with reality and how we live our lives
so I think I'm really excited to kind of
keep exploring that stuff too me too
yeah well thanks for making time yeah
thanks for having me on this podcast and
thanks for you it thanks for the
questions to is really good yeah dog one
- one of the best
you